[موسيقى]
في الظرف الراهن لم تعد اهميه هذا المنتدى
تقتصر على روسيا فحسب اثبات مهما للعالم
اجمع ولد في اوقات عصيبه تزامنا مع بدايات
تجسيد منظوماتنا الاقتصاديه وقليل من امن
بان تكون النتيجه مثيره للاهتمام فانا
اتذكر هذا التحفظ اما الان فقد اصبح هذا
المنتدى واحدا من المنصات الدوليه الرائده
يتوافد سنويا لحضوره عدد كبير من الشخصيات
ذائعه الصيت في مجالات المال والاعمال
والسياسه حيث يتم ابرام العديد من العقود
في هذا العام يشارك نحو 130 الى 140 دوله
بهذا المنتدى
[موسيقى]
هذه المنطقه بالنسبه لنا شريك طبيعي لما
لدينا من اهتمامات مشتركه ومشروعات مشتركه
كالطاقه وقضايا الامن والتصدي للارهاب
بالاضافه الان الى التدفق السياحي اذ ان
هذه الوجهات باتت مالوفه بالنسبه لمواطنين
فهي تنال اعجابهم وشغفهم والحديث هنا عن
بعض الجوانب في هذا الاطار فقط فضلا عن
معالجه الكثير من القضايا بالتنسيق
المشترك في الشرق الاوسط وفي العالم ككل
لذا نحن نطور هذه العلاقات بناء على
التعاون الثنائي وبصيغه التعاون متعدد
الاقطاب ونعتبر ان لدينا مخزونا هائلا في
هذا السياق
[موسيقى]